o mundo dos maiores enigmas da
humanidade eu queria que respondesse
agora o que que só dá vontade de cagar
depois que tomou banho já não tem como
enxugar o malhar porque o papel rasga
que não dá para voltar para chuveiro só
para lavar o que é muita humilhação
carne algo manda mensagem Eu Venci sou
eu que mando nessa O que é que o
organismo pensa nesse momento já escovou
o dente já comeu diga canal parabólica
agora não cleonaldo pelo amor de Deus
não tenho coisas mais importantes para
fazer né Ai meu Deus vai a cada um que
me aparece ela te pediu a caixa de foto
Leonildo ninguém tá o dia todinho sem
carregar ai meu Deus se da diarreia tava
o dia todinho reclama se não cabe o dia
todinho reclama também eu não sei o que
eu passar não vou largar mão disso aqui
é muito
não tem coisa para preocupar mas eu não
tô querendo incomodar não tá longe de
mim incomodado tá pegando a toalha para
tomar banho e